Ja, das ist ein wirklich krasses foto, der nasa ist es jetzt gelungen erstmalig im bild festzuhalten
Wie sich ein schwarzes loch beim fressen verhält und jetzt haltet euch fest, es wird richtig menschlich ist
Macht ein nickerchen holst und frist wieder ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und es ist wirklich fantastisch
Wie es aussieht
Wenn ein schwarzes loch gleich zweimal selbst und was der grund für diese
Schlechte tischmanieren ist jetzt ein klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir berichten hier ja immer wieder mal über schwarze löcher und viele von euch wissen wohl was schwarze löcher am besten können nämlich
Materie aufsaugen, wenn es keine materie rund um ihr schwerefeld mehr gibt warten sie geduldig ab
Wir sind wieder zuschlagen können und materie verschlingen, danach stoßen sie einen strahl an partikeln aus
Das war jetzt die mehr oder weniger
Physikalische erklärung für das was waren auf diesem bild, der nasa jetzt erstmalig sehen
Kann ein schwarzes loch das obst und wie konkret geht es dabei um die galaxie?
Sdss york bereit sind wir 50 plus 13 27
Die etwa 800 millionen lichtjahre von unserer erde entfernt ist
Sie befindet sich im sternbild bärenhüter und in ihrem zentrum ist ein super massereiches schwarzes loch
das millionenfach schwerer als unsere sonne ist und ihm ist wohl der pop art mit dem höchsten passiert, die
beteiligte forscherin, juli comerford von der university of colorado boulder
Selbst assoziiert das mit menschlichem verhalten zitat schwarze löcher sind ganz schön gefräßig
Aber sie haben keine sehr gute tischmanieren, das besondere an diesem bild ist
dass das schwarze loch gleich zweimal auf stößt das alles wurde vom satelliten chandra aufgenommen und auf der
231 tagung der american astronomical society im januar vorgestellt konkret zu sehen sind zwei
Gasblasen eine unterhalb und die andere oberhalb des schwarzen lochs dazu
Juli, cover fort wir sehen
Wie das schwarze loch frist ein nickerchen macht dann wieder frisst und drückt genau wie theoretisch vorhergesagt
Mann habe wohl etwas glück gehabt, dass man diese galaxie genau zu diesem zeitpunkt beobachtet
Habe indem diese eindeutigen beweise zu sehen sind ihren untersuchungen zufolge sind diese blasen, oder?
Eben gas rückseite zu unterschiedlichen zeiten aufgetreten aus der geschwindigkeit, der blasen schließt
Das forschungsteam das sowohl in einem abstand von etwa
100.000 jahren ausgespuckt wurden kaum, der rede wert, also im vergleich mit dem alter des universums das auf
13,8 milliarden jahre geschätzt wird für das schwarze loch so etwas wie für uns der abstand vom frühstück bis zum mittagessen
Oder warum hat es gleich zweimal gefressen und noch zweimal gerüst das forschungsteam vermutet
Dass es zu einer kollision mit einer nahen galaxie kamen so
Dass große mengen an kosmischen gas als futter dient es gab
Also, zwei gänge total ungewöhnlich sind solche tischmanieren übrigens nicht auch das schwarze loch in der milchstraße
Also in unserer galaxie im zentrum hat wohl mindestens einmal in den letzten paar millionen jahren gerade macht es wohl ein
Verdauungs schläfchen, wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
Dann könnt euch hierbei whatsapp an, dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
Ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen
Der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit
Genau, der glocken vergessen, hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken außerirdisches leben, super erde entdeckt ansonsten. Bis dann
Bleibt dran?